[Music]
there's something that you do that
intrigues me and I actually kind of
enjoyed it it seems like you go out of
your way because we were talking earlier
on the show about how celebrities have
Twitter followers right yes and you
almost seem to go out of your way to
annoy them is that true no I just the
thing is is that you Twitter is very
hard to be ironic on because whatever
you say people just believe you I
tweeted I was gonna be on the show and I
heard that Josh was gonna be on and I
said very Joe Kelly I'm um with some guy
called Josh from a film called hungry
games question mark I know what it's
called
yeah within one minute I had like it's
good games you idiot these people just
like yeah they may not have a sense of
humor about that movie but you but you
okay that's an innocent mistake yeah but
you like to torture some of your Twitter
followers you really do we did yes
you're referring to the ghost yes yes
your honor
case no yeah I I did a thing once you're
referring to the ghost incident yes one
morning I woke up in my loft door was
open the the attic door was open if I
can do that it's one of the line yes you
could do that as a flappy door flappy
door yeah and for watching that the
sound on
I think we're telling a dirty story but
your your attic it's the access to the
attic the door yes do we call it an
attic here attic okay it's an attic what
do you call it a loft
it's like segments over no so if you
want freedom say attic yeah no and I
said it was open on Twitter I said
that's a bit creepy and people going oh
you've got a ghost it's paranormal
activity so then I said I woke up in the
morning and my dog was underneath
looking up at it and it was shut which
was a lie right and then I don't know
what it shut it was shown yeah yeah like
that yeah and then I and then the next
morning I said it's open again and I
started to get the people genuinely like
you'd there's something going on man
there's something in your attic get up
there and so I said I said right I'm
gonna go up this is my tweeting mine I'm
gonna go up there and check what's going
on and then I didn't tell you for three
days
[Applause]
this is the thing I got my I got my best
friend Nick Frost who the dawn of the
day funny Nick Frost my sister Kate to
to tweet I'm just going around to see if
Simon's okay I haven't heard from him by
then they didn't tweet for three days
after day two I wrote to a friend of
mine in Greece and got the the Greek
translation for the for the sentence
they are my children now do not try to
find them they are with me also enlist
and I and I tweeted it in Greek script
so that all the people are on Google gun
was it me what did it mean oh my god
you know what annoyed people was then in
three days later I just said Oh
everything's fine you know nothing's
there yeah but I tweeted it like five
minutes after I'd tweeted the original
message but three days later yeah as if
it was like I hadn't realized time had
passed that was my thing I got so much
hate for like that's a it's a bad ending
that's that you can't you can't that's
like you know it was like I'd written
lost or something as if the Greek ghost
is better yeah I had a great ghost in
mind that was really creative I thought
yeah okay no please well you're on the
right show for that
Shaun of the Dead very popular film and
and and it's reached a level of cult
status where I told that Legos is
considering immortalizing you and is it
at you and a zombie character it's
myself it actually it's a whole scene
from I don't know if you've seen the
movie but we end up in a pub called the
Winchester yeah and it's a Winchester
Road it's a zombie siege in a pub but
it's as it's a lego pub filled with
zombies and the characters leg someone
has presented it as a possible Lego
thing and it's wake up thinking about
doing it you need 10,000 votes we have a
photo of this is the actual so we could
actually affect the vote go to Lego calm
now and vote for Shaun of the Dead Lego
yeah if you want your children to play
with dead